foreign
[Music]
product manager in Google and today I'm
going to talk about building
applications with unmasked scale and
reliability with transformative
databases and in this case the
transformative databases Cloud spanner
so I have full uh packed agenda so let's
dive right into it so first I am going
to introduce Cloud spanner to you talk
about some of the industry use cases
which people are building with spanner
talk about a particular Financial
Services scalable architecture use case
where they are using spanner so to give
you an understanding of how a scalable
workloads are built on spanner and last
but not the least we'll talk about some
of the latest Innovations and highlights
within spanner
so let's talk about what is cloud
spanner so Cloud spanner is a fully
managed horizontally scalable relational
database service so there's a lot which
is packed into that particular statement
fully managed so basically you don't
have to worry about binary upgrades
applying patches and everything we take
care of that for you on the horizontal
scalability this is something which you
probably have uh heard from
non-relational databases spanner does
automatic sharding of data it's a
distributed rdms and has near unlimited
scale
uh so that is something which is offered
to you without compromising on
consistency so it's a fully relational
database service with full SQL support
asset transactions schemas and
everything
uh this uh zero maintenance downtime
service so something you don't have to
worry about even the schema changes are
applied uh while you are completely
online uh it offers zero rpu zero RTO in
case of a zonal failure in a regional
instance and uh zero rpo0 IQ in case of
a regional 3D and a multivisional
instance
and yes zero touch Global replication
all the security and compliance which
you can hold from a Enterprise database
service in terms of metrics spana is
extremely scalable so spanner processes
over 2 billion requests per second at
Peak and has more than six extra bites
of data under management speaks about
the scale at which spanner operates as
you know Google has a number of billion
plus user product and a number of them
are running on Savannah
in terms of Industry verticals and use
cases by no means this is a
comprehensive list of all industry
verticals but just calling out the six
here there are multiple more span is
extremely popular in gaming with user
profile and uh and leaderboard and
real-time gameplay data all those use
cases film sub uh customers are building
uh online digital banks on spanner with
full user account data ledgers are built
on spanner Healthcare we have full EMR
systems being developed on spanner
retail we have a Supply Chain management
inventory data on span are extremely
popular with retailers around the world
technology we have real-time decision
making workloads on spanner and last but
not least media entertainment is digital
Rights Management catalog metadata a
number of those kind of use cases this
is just a snapshot of customers and they
are uh like so many of them we can't
talk about each each one but as you you
saw in the previous slide gaming we have
Bandai Namco we have come to us
retailers we have Macy's here Home Depot
here a lot of other customers and Retail
using it uh in terms of financial
services we have PayPal Goldman Sachs
ANZ bank again some very Mega Banks and
services who for the next generation of
architecture are using spanner in terms
of healthcare we have David uh building
an EMR system on spanner technology we
have share chat and Snapchat and video
so a lot of customers are trusting their
workloads with Spanish
now let's talk about the scalable
architecture withstana as I mentioned
I'll use a finserv customer use case so
uh some of their functional and
Technical requirements are mentioned on
the slide on the functional side
customers want transactions with full
traceability uh they want to make sure
you can meet their availability
requirements slas which are set by their
regulatory bodies they want to have
scaling on demand and they want to pay
for what they're using they want Best in
Class security controls and last not the
least you as a cloud provider should be
qualified by the regulatory body to
offer services and in terms of technical
requirement just mapping to the
functional one they want higher
availability
near zero operational overhead and
ability to scheme seamlessly scale the
workload based on demand and uh last but
not least they want uh availability of
operational data in real time and
analytical systems so they can drive
insights and make business decisions
based Shuffle that
this is just uh the representative
architecture of an omnichannel banking
use case you can see a customer is
accessing the same data from different
channels whether it's mobile web uh
through a API Gateway and on the
operational side it's something to call
out is with operational with scalable
operational database like spanner you
want a scalable compute which is gke so
gke and spanner kind of solution from
architecture standpoint we see as a very
common architectural pattern and then
you have Integrations into different
analytical systems whether it's bigquery
via data flow pops up and all kinds of
stuff we provide you like seamless
integration into some of these other gcp
services and then there's governance
which is offered through security and
like nkms and some of the other services
which are there
now let's talk about some of the latest
Innovations and highlights which we have
in spanner and we'll start with uh
initiative called as democratization of
scanner this has been in the works for
quite some time and we have launched a
lot of capabilities related to this and
democratization spanner includes two
main elements one is the cost second one
is improving the familiarity and
providing a familiar interface to access
span on the cost front uh one of the key
uh like capabilities which we recently
introduced is committed use discounts so
what is Cuts or committed use discounts
basically in lieu of your commitment to
spanner we offer you discount on your
compute capacity which is note pricing
you can say or processing units so uh if
if uh if a customer user makes a
one-year commitment on spanner we give
20 discount
and for three year commitment is 40
discount the these are spend based
committed use discounts so extremely
flexible so you can just comment okay
I'm going to spend let's say hundred
dollars or one thousand dollars an hour
on spanner and you can apply those
discounts on whether in particular
region or multi-region anywhere so it's
extremely flexible that way and it gives
you full utilization of what you have
committed for
next is granular instance sizing so as
you probably know a single node in
spanner can do quite a bit uh just based
on ycsb test one node in spanner can do
10 000 reads or two thousand writes now
that's quite a lot uh probably mostly
suited for larger workloads now there's
customers who said hey we have smaller
workloads and we want that four nines or
five nines of availability for them or
we want that scale insurance which
provide and which spanner provides or
I'm using spanner for this workload and
I want to just standardize on spanner
for everything so for those kind of use
cases and everything we are here we have
launched Grand lines and sizing so with
that we introduce a union unit called as
Processing Unit so one spanner node will
be equal to 1000 processing units and
you can buy as less as like 100
processing units so you get proportional
resources for proportional price so
almost for 65 a month you can get
started on spanner with 100 Processing
Unit Regional instance get get four
lines of availability and then you can
scale with 100 200 300 all the way up to
1000 and then two thousand three
thousand and in fact you can apply
committed use discounts on top of uh
granular instance sizing as well so you
can almost get started less than forty
dollars a month if you buy a three year
committed use discount on top of span so
extremely uh cost efficient uh and
ideally suited for smaller and
medium-sized workloads and we have seen
massive adoption for Uganda instances uh
within spanner as the same product with
the same SLA
uh we just launched free trial instance
and the uh what exactly our free trial
instances what what do we offer so
basically you get one free instance uh
per project and you get 10 GB of storage
for free and you get a 90-day free trial
period with that and uh you can create a
free trial instance you can keep the
tiles with spanner we have provided
tutorials sample apps so you can get
familiarize yourself with spanner very
easily and it offers a lot of those
capabilities which are available in
spana anyways and it's much easier for
you to now try out spanner and get used
to it we provide you flexibility to
upgrade to a paid instance any period of
time within those 90 days and if you are
not operated 90 days we'll give you one
month of race period with that and uh
it's kind of extremely uh popular Within
in our customers as well as prospects so
please give it a try and let us know
what your feedback is
and last but not the least on the cost
front uh democratization spanner we have
a free local emulator where you can
which you can use for your unit test and
CI CD pipeline you can make it into that
we also have a community contributed
autoscaler which a lot of our customers
are using so it can automatically scale
and scale up and down your workloads it
has flexible deployments models and
depending on your choice you can use it
now let's come to the familiarity aspect
in the whole democratization of Spanish
initiatives so earlier this year we
launched postgres SQL interface on
spanner and GA now the goal of us
introducing PG interface on spanner was
uh family ID so we want customers to use
spanner for all the goodness which it
provides whether it's high availability
whether it's that uh near a limited
scale and without compromising
consistency with a familiar interface
like postgres because a lot of customers
a lot of users are already
familiar with PG so they don't have to
go through that onboarding Ram to
understand Google SQL and I use our
proprietary apis so that was the key
goal uh application portability you can
get so what forbid if for whatever
reason you have to exit out of spanner
you have built your application with
postgres SQL interface so it would be
much easier for you to to Port out of
spanner and definitely it will help you
in accelerating adoption or spanner
within your organization
so one thing to note is a hundred
percent compatibility with postgres is
not our goal means what we are aiming
for is providing you connectivity with
the wire protocol support tools drivers
orms full processing support with query
dialect functions and on the storage
side most important aspect for us is
data Fidelity is maintained so we'll
provide uh data types support for
postgres data types ddl indexes so for
example varchar is a data type which is
supported on postgres SQL interface and
we want to make sure you have access to
those same familiar data types and again
with postgres you get all the same
things with spanner offers with a
familiar dialect
now let's talk about some of the key
Enterprise and developer capabilities
which we have introduced uh recently
first and foremost let's talk about
standard chain streams so this is native
CDC uh change data capture capability
into spanner extremely flexible so
basically a user can configure a chain
stream on multiple change streams on
their database whether you want to
listen to a column multiple different
groups of columns or a table or an
entire database you can just issue a ddl
and you can configure your chain streams
it will basically the street change
streams are
synchronously updated so it's strongly
consistent that's the way we have built
it internally and you have you can
configure the change tune data to be
retained aluminum period of one day to
uh up to seven days depends on what your
needs are and we have given like uh
managed connectors to you with the data
flow connect which is available now you
can use a data flow connector and you
can you have templates by which you can
plump your data into different uh like
things so for example there are three
main use cases which customers use
change streams for first and foremost is
analytics so you want to
keep on replicating all the data changes
from your operational data into your
analytical database so in this case
let's say bigquery so you can do that
there's a data flow connector and a
template for that you want to trigger
Downstream applications based on changes
which are happening in your oltp data
database so that is also available and
last but not the least uh you want to
archive all the changes which are
happening in your operational database
into GCS that is possible through
auditing And archiving
ah
next is finding access control so
spanner today supports IM based database
level access controls now on top of that
customers requested hey I want final
level controls like table level column
level lockers So based off of that and
especially this is from a lot of our
regulatory even retail customers so we
are introducing Finland access control
system preview please give it a try it's
traditional SQL role-based access
control and uh it works in conjunction
with fine view and access control so
very easy to use different use cases as
listed on the slide departmental access
if you want to provide only Regional
access if you want to provide you can
enable a bunch of these
and uh SEC now let's talk about vertex
AI integration so this is an extremely
cool capability uh a lot of customers
requested that that hey we want to in
real time derive insights through
machine learning models and inform our
transactions based off of that so with
that we are announcing vertex AI
integration spanner with spanner ml so
what you can do is you can register a
Vertex AI model into your database via
issuing a ddl and then you can invoke
that vertex AI model via a span ml
command from within a transaction so it
definitely is very easy from a
development standpoint improves your
efficiency overall over transaction
latency you can experience with this
because otherwise if you have to do it
outside it's a very involved process so
for example in this particular use case
it's shown that you have item selected
you do a checkout and then you to do the
saml.traduct there's a model which has
already registered and database and you
invoke that and you pass on the data
from spanner it runs it via the machine
learning model and then the module
results are served by a spanner and then
you can know whether it was a safe
transaction or something which you have
to review so extremely cool capability
and last we continue working on
improving uh this is more on the
developer capability side providing a
support for Java and Google applications
by supporting gdbc for Java and PGX will
go for postgres so you can have full
portability and scalability for
applications which are you in developing
via the postgres SQL interface on
spanner
and building on some of those developer
capabilities so we launched query
insights earlier I uh this is an
extremely popular launch where if you
see high CPU utilization you can go
through the step three-step journey of
confirmed confirm identify and analyze
to exactly know what was the reason for
high CPU utilization and diagnose it and
fix it
and building on query insights I'm happy
to announce that we'll soon be launching
transaction and lock-in sites as well
value similar to query insights you will
have pre-built dashboards for developers
to troubleshoot high latencies due to
lock contentions you can exactly see and
relate the row ranges with higher lock
contentions which are there so like a
very helpful capability
for a lot of customers and with this I'd
like to conclude on the next steps there
are a bunch of resources listed here
please stay in touch with us try out
spanner via the cloud spanner free trial
and keep on keep on providing us
feedback on any requests which you may
have with this I'd like to thank you for
your time and attention uh I hope you
enjoy the rest of next thank you
[Music]